I'm good. I'm good. Um, so the Quran, it
has a consistent preserved message from
God, but the Bible has centuries of
compilation and translation. So, how can
we trust it if it has some textual
mistakes?
>> How can you trust that the Quran is has
a consistent theological message if the
message that it deres from is corrupted
and full of mistakes?
>> No, the Bible. The Bible. So, how do you
know the what is the Quran consistent
with then? When you say the Quran has a
consistent theological message, what is
it consistent with?
>> Like like it isn't translated. It's in
the same language. Same.
>> No, it's not.
>> No, no, it is. It is. But
>> No, I mean like it's like we have the
original one, but y'all don't. So, how
can y'all?
>> Yeah, we do. We got We got We got Hebrew
and Greek Bibles. Bro, you talking
>> No, I know. I mean I mean like it has
mistakes in it, doesn't it?
>> No.
>> Yes, it does. It has.
>> Okay. So, so if if it has m if the if
the Bible has mistakes in it, then how
do you know that the Quran is has a
consistent theological message? Because
it's supposed to be reliant on those
books that came before it, right?
>> No,
>> that's what the Quran says.
>> No. No, it doesn't.
>> Yes, it does. It says that the Quran
came confirming what came before it. So,
it has to be consistent with what came
before. But no, no, it doesn't have to
mean it doesn't have to mean that u that
that the other texts it like it doesn't
mean that it has to be now. It can be
before too. God sent the other the other
books. It sent those now. So I mean like
those books they're now corrupted but
the one corrupted before the Quran came
after it.
>> Were they corrupted in Muhammad's time?
Were they corrupted in Muhammad's time?
Hello Muhammad.
>> Muhammad's time.
Yes, they were.
>> Okay. So the Quran says in Muhammad's
time that it's confirming the scriptures
that's there in Muhammad's time with the
Jews and Christians. So the
[clears throat] Quran if they're
corrupted, why would the Quran be saying
that it's consistent with corrupted
scriptures? You understand what I'm
saying?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I heard you saw you doing
this against Hashim. He debunked it,
[clears throat] but I forgot what it
was. So
>> you think Hasham debunked it?
>> Hash? Yeah. Yeah. Hashim he debunked it
>> by just talking?
>> Yeah. saying
>> the the Quran verse it was it it was a
verse I think it was uh the second surah
it says that um that why do you trust
the Bible and like like the other stuff
if they have and and woe to those who
have written it with their own hands.
>> So bro all all Hasham did was affirm the
problem. He didn't escape it. He
affirmed that the scriptures are
corrupted which then has Allah
confirming corrupted scriptures. That's
that's the problem Hashem fell into.
>> All right. Tell me tell me the uh verse.
What is the verse that say
>> chapter 2 verse 41 it says believe in
what I have sent down or believe in what
I've revealed confirming that which is
already with you.
>> Okay. Yeah. So
>> you got to get a new battery battery for
that uh fire detector, man. So,
>> but he's saying like, how do you know?
He's saying to the um he's he's telling
the Christians and Jews to to believe
the Quran,
>> right? Why why should they believe the
Quran according to the verse?
>> Is is because the truth?
>> No.
>> What type of question is that?
>> No. He tells them why. What is what is
the reason why they should believe in
the Quran? He tells them right there in
the verse. What does it say? Chapter 2,
verse 41. Brother, if you're if you're
there, I know you're typing and stuff.
>> Yeah. I'm trying to look for I think I
have a copy of
>> Do you have a Quran?
>> Yeah. One sec. I'm just gonna
>> Okay, one second. I got a copy of the
Quran.
>> Okay. You got you got you got the
physical Quran.
>> Yeah, the uh the English one. So,
>> I like I like you, man. A lot of Muslims
don't have the physical Quran on them,
man.
>> Okay. Let me see. Believe. Okay.
>> Dang, that beep is loud. Chapter 2,
verse 41. So what would you say is the
uh context of that verse?
>> Allah is trying to convince the Jews to
believe in the Quran as well.
>> Yeah, but like like what's the mistake
you're saying? Like
>> it's not a mistake.
>> Do you see how Allah tells them to
believe in what he revealed? What he
sent down?
>> Yeah.
>> What is already with them?
>> Affirming what is with them.
>> It says that, right?
>> But um
>> wait, wait. Do you see that? It says
that.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I do. I do. So therefore,
Allah's telling them they need to
believe in the Quran because it's it
confirms what they have already, the
scriptures they have.
>> Yeah. But the confirmation is is uh is
referred to the shared message of all
the prophets.
>> It doesn't say that. It just says
confirm what confirming what they have
their scriptures. So it says that their
scriptures are true. The Quran is in
line with those. That's why they should
also believe the Quran.
It says, "Believe my in my revelations
which are which confirm your scriptures.
Do not be the first to deny them or
trade them for fitting gain."
>> Yep. So, you see how he says they should
believe in the Quran because it confirms
their scriptures, right? Um,
>> but but how do you know it's saying it
like uh like how do you know she's
saying it like like in the ones that
they have right now?
>> Well, first we're dealing with what in
Muhammad's time. So the Quran came down
and then says to the Jews, "Believe in
the Quran which confirms your scriptures
that you have." So in Muhammad's time,
the Quran is saying the scriptures that
are there in Muhammad's time are good.
>> Okay,
>> make sense?
>> So in so in Muhammad's time, the the the
Torah was corrupted. Yes.
>> No, it wasn't.
>> It wasn't
>> because if it if it was if it was
corrupted, the Quran wouldn't be
confirming it.
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. But in in my view, Yeah.
So,
>> what do you mean in your view?
>> Okay.
>> Your view your view has to match the
Quran, right?
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> The Quran's view is that the Torah is
not corrupted. It's perfectly intact.
That's why it confirms it. It confirms
the Torah in Muhammad's time.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But look, it says it says
and that and that word means to verify
and and and it is to like
>> to affirm the truth. Yeah. No. To affirm
the truth of that that scripture.
>> Yes. Yes. The Quran is affirming the
truth of their scriptures.
>> No. No. It's saying but but but look at
the words. It says which is like um it
means to verify or to affirm the truth
of or to attest to. So in other words,
it's saying that the truth that remains
from earlier revelations and not the
alterations or the additions.
>> It doesn't say anything about
alterations. It says what they have with
them is true. It's attesting to the
truth of what they have, the scriptures
they have currently in my time.
>> Yeah, but just English. It can't it
can't exactly copy.
>> I'm talking about the Arabic. I'm
talking about the Arabic.
>> Okay.
>> It says
uh ma, right?
>> Yeah. But
>> what does what does ma mean?
>> Ma with with you all.
>> Exactly. So the it's attesting to the
truth of the scripture they have with
them. So the scripture they have with
them, the Quran is verifying that it's
true. It's saying it's good.
>> Yeah. But but when it says and then it's
saying with you, but it can it can mean
like the previous ones doesn't have.
>> No, it's not the previous ones. They
have it. They have it with them. It says
it's with them.
>> Says it's with them. So yeah, it's with
them. But it's just
>> how how is there a butt after that?
There's no Yeah, it's with them. But no,
it's that it should be the the end all.
[clears throat] That's it. It's with
them.
>> But he's saying it but it's it's
affirming it. So it's not like it's like
how do you know that whether it's saying
the one with you that's corrupted or the
one with you is because is because they
like messed the whole thing up.
>> All right. All right. Let's let's I
don't know how to how else to reach
these kids. Let's think about let's
let's really think about this little
bro.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> The the the verse says that they have
the scriptures with them, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And what it says about those
scriptures that they have with them is
that the Quran confirms them. It it
attests to their truthfulness. Meaning
it's saying that they're true. So the
Quran in this verse says that according
to the Quran, the scriptures they have
with them are true. If they were
corrupted, they couldn't be true. So you
have two options here. Option number
one, the Quran is very clear in that the
Torah in Muhammad's time is true and
good to go uncorrupted. or option number
two that the Quran that the Torah is
corrupted in Muhammad's time and the
Quran is saying that a corrupted book is
true. Which of the two options are you
going to go with? Is the is the Quran
confirming a true book or is it
confirming a corrupted book?
>> Okay. But so
what is with you? Yeah. So it's saying
in in Quranic language it refers to the
revelation that they possessed. So in
name but not necessarily the pure
unchanged scripture. Let's look at that.
No, no, it says the revelation they
possessed that they had in name. Name or
tradition, but it has it doesn't
necessarily have to be the pure
unchanged scripture.
>> Okay, I got you. So which option are you
taking? The Torah is true. Number two,
>> the Torah is true or the Quran is
confirming a corrupted book. The Quran
is confirming a true book or the Quran
is confirming a corrupted book. Which
one is? Quran is confirming the the true
one that was there before Muhammad's
time because it doesn't necessarily have
to mean that it's the unchanged
scripture.
>> I'm going to do this. I'm going to do
this one last time and then if you can't
get this then I'm dusting my hands off
and I'm going to leave you to yourself
and leave you to Islam cuz I don't have
time for this. I don't. It's either
you're going to be honest with your text
or you're going to be dishonest like the
rest of the Muslims I deal with.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> But I'm not going to continue to waste
my time. Be honest with your own verses.
Stop trying to put a band-aid over what
Allah says because it doesn't match what
you believe. It says what it says.
That's it. That's all. Stop trying to
reinterpret it. Does it say that the
Quran is confirming scriptures that's
with them or that's not with them? What
does it say? Does it say it's with them?
>> With them.
>> Okay. Does that mean with them or does
it mean they don't have it?
>> It can mean a name.
>> Get off my stage. It can mean a name.
Get off my stage. Insane. Islam is in a
world of trouble. Islam is in a world of
trouble. It's in a world of trouble.
Johnny, if Sarah has an apple in one
hand, and she has another apple in
another hand, how many apples? Johnny.
Uh, she only can taste the apples, but
she doesn't really have them.
>> Hello.
>> Hi, Tim. How you doing?
>> Yeah, I'm fine, man. How are you? Good.
>> I'm good. So you talk about $2,000 or
$2,000 for someone prove to you Muhammad
is in the Bible or what?
>> That's right.
>> You see Jesus Jesus was Muslim.
>> Yeah. If you prove that Jesus was a
Muslim, you get this money.
>> Yeah. How do you prove he's a Muslim
from your Bible?
>> Yes. That would be the best way to do
it.
>> Yeah. But do you think it's unfair to
ask us something? It's in your book.
>> No, because you're making a claim.
You're making a claim about somebody
that's in my book. So
>> yeah, but you should you should reject
this. Look, he was Christian. He ate
pork, he ate ham, he drink alcohol, he
ble to the father, he he was a god, he
he had a cross, he built the churches
like he should be doing no other way
around. Look at that.
>> So you agree that Jesus was not a
Muslim? You agree?
>> No, I'm not I'm saying any I just I'm
telling you the the fallacy making here.
It's just a it's just it's just if he
look if he is not Muslim did what just
do to be not Muslims? Look, did he did
Jesus?
>> Well, first well, first you got to prove
that he's a Muslim, my friend. And then
we could get to the other parts.
>> Islam Islam is a is is not a name or a
title. It's an action. It's an acting.
If you are a Muslims and you don't pray,
you're not Muslim. You know, if you are
a Muslim, don't believe the Quran
hadith, you're not Muslim. So what Jesus
do in his life? Did Jesus worship one
God like Muslim? Yes, he worship God one
God like all Muslim do. worship one god.
Pause there cuz that's important.
Muslims worship one God. Jesus worship
one God. Did Jesus worship the same God
that the Muslims worship?
>> No. Let me finish first and then you
could ask me step by step. Don't ask me.
Don't stop me cuz I want to do it. I
will stick to one minute. Yeah,
>> we're we're No. No. We're going to stick
to one thing that you mentioned. We're
going to deal We're going to deal with
one point at a time.
>> So, did Jesus worship did Jesus worship
the same God that Muslims worship? Yeah,
he he worshiped the one God the same us.
Exactly.
>> Okay. So, can you show me the God that
Jesus worshiped? Who? Show me who Jesus
says he was.
>> He said he he say he said is only true
is God. God mean Allah in the Quran.
>> No, he said he said the only true God is
who?
>> Is is God?
>> No. No. He said he said you are the only
true God. Who is the you that he's
talking to?
>> To his to his to to his creator. It
doesn't say that. So, who does he say is
the only true God?
>> You You tell us then. I didn't know. You
tell us. Go ahead.
>> You don't know. You didn't read the
verse.
>> No, I would love to know from you. Go
ahead.
>> It says his father.
>> Where said his father
>> in verse one,
>> you talk about uh he he said God.
>> No, he said father.
>> Not father.
>> He said father.
>> Which Bible do you read?
>> It doesn't matter. Just open any Bible
and go to John 17:1.
>> John, what what did it say? John 17:3.
Am I right?
>> Verse one.
>> One second.
>> Okay.
>> One second. One sec. Look, it says to
you here, "And this eternal life that
they know you that
>> Can you read verse one, brother? Can you
read verse one?"
>> Let me get the Bible. Let me get the
Bible. All of it in front of me.
>> Thank you.
>> No problem. But are you going to read
Let me read all of it. Yeah,
>> I promise I will.
>> Very good. I'm glad you did this. I'm
I'm glad you very very understandable
today.
>> Thank you.
>> No problem. Right. First one, Jesus
prayed to God to be glorified. Right?
Shall I? After Jesus said this, he
looked toward this heaven and prayed,
"Father, the hour has come. Glory your
son that your son may glor glory glorify
you for you granted him authority over
all people that he he might give eternal
life to all those you have given him.
now in eternal life that you that know
you the only true God and Jesus Christ
who whom you have sent.
>> So So who does he say is the only true
God?
>> Him. Only true God. He said
>> yeah. Who does he say? Who is that?
>> He said you look he said look it say
>> yeah. Who is the you that he says is the
only true God?
>> He tell us cuz I was just telling you he
said God.
>> Read read verse one again. Who is Jesus
talking to in verse one? He says to you,
"Father, the hour has comes."
>> So who he talking?
>> So who is he talking to?
>> Yeah. You mean father? Yeah. You mean
father? You want to talk about father?
>> Not me. Not me. Who did Jesus say he's
talking to?
>> Man, he's talking to his father. To his
god. Father.
>> To his father. Okay, good. Now, so
Jesus, I got you. So Jesus says I got
you.
>> So Jesus says that the only true God is
his father. Correct?
>> No, God. It says God here. only true
God. Look, I open the camera for you.
>> I'm going to give you I'mma give you
another chance. I'm going to give you
another chance.
>> Look, look.
>> Jesus is talking to his father who he
says is the true God. Is that correct?
>> Yeah. God, not father. God,
>> watch your head on the way out.
>> Watch your head,
>> bro. Just read it. He said,
>> "No."
>> Oh my god.
>> He just read it.
>> No. [laughter]
Wow, bro. I love these people, man. Yo,
>> Islam, bro. How you doing, Ysef?
>> I'm doing great. I'm doing great, man.
How about you?
>> Good. I'm pretty good, man.
>> Hope you're safe. So, my question is,
what are your standards of uh Jesus
being Muslim?
>> Okay. Yeah, good question. So if you can
prove historically from historically
reliable sources on where we get the our
information about Jesus, who he is, what
he was, what he believed, um and you
could demonstrate that from those
sources that he uh followed the religion
of Islam, that he preached a Muslim
message, that he practiced Islam, um
then therefore you prove that he's a
Muslim.
>> What does Muslim mean? First of all,
>> I I I'm pretty sure you and I will have
a different definition of it. So I I
would I
>> has one definition in the okay it's it's
someone who submits his will to God.
>> Okay
>> that's what Muslim means.
>> Now if we look at it what's God in
Aramaic?
>> The word God doesn't matter. It varies
in different languages. It matters who
it matters who you say God is.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Sure. But what does it mean in in
Aramaic?
>> What what did Jesus call uh God?
>> You you got to show me what Jesus called
God. just translate what's God in
Aramaic.
>> Why would I do that? How do you know?
How do you know that that's what he
called? What do
>> you mean? Why?
>> How do you know that that's what he
said?
>> English. Did Jesus speak English?
>> He he spoke many different languages. He
spoke Aramaic. He spoke Greek. He spoke
Hebrew
>> and poss and possibly Latin as well.
>> Okay. So my question, what is God is one
of the language he spoke?
>> What is what is it in one of the
languages? Theos.
>> Yeah.
>> Or his main language. Because if you
So so he spoke different languages.
>> Okay. Okay. Let's say that relevant that
he he called God Allah.
>> Why not?
>> Why not? Why not theos? Cuz he spoke
Greek too. So why not theos?
>> There are different different
interpretations but one God.
>> I I got See, so do you see how it
doesn't matter what language we're
talking about? God is God and then it
and for whatever the word is in whatever
language
>> and then um
>> okay
>> but it matters who you're saying that
God is who you who you say that Allah is
who you say that theos is who you say
that Allah is right
>> so Allah is someone who has no partners
there is one god one creator that we are
supposed to submit to
>> okay does he uh
>> so if we look does he have children
>> no children as in as in what sense? As
in as in what sense?
>> In any sense
>> I mean when David said that he's a
father does that mean that he's a his
father?
>> That's why I ask in any sense. In any
sense
>> is the [clears throat] God of Islam a
father.
>> We can say father but not in as in the
sense that he took a child.
>> Okay. So just to be clear cuz that's
what a father is. Someone who took a
child whether it's
there could be a godfather. There could
be a father figure. Does that mean that
they intentionally like
>> Yeah. If you're a if you're a father if
you're a father figure that means that
you have uh like you have you're that
role model to that child of yours,
right? Like
>> but are you his father? That's the
question. Are you his father?
>> Yes. In just not a biological sense.
>> I just told you.
>> Yes. We not in the biological sense.
That's what we reject.
>> Okay. So So you're saying So you're
saying that Allah is a father just not
in a biological sense. Is that right?
>> Sure, you can say that.
>> All right. Can you show me where your
Quran says that
>> any sense or say say God is one?
>> No. Can you show me in your Quran, Ysef?
>> That's the Quran, brother. I'm I'm
reciting something.
>> Slow down. Slow down. You just said that
you can affirm that Allah is a father,
just not in a biological sense. Okay.
>> Yes.
>> So, can you show me in the Quran? Hold
on. Just Larry, listen to the listen to
the class.
>> Can you show me in the Quran? Listen to
the questioning.
>> Can you can you be quiet while I ask the
question so you know what you're
answering to? Okay. Can you show me in
the Quran
>> where it says that Allah is a father in
some sense?
>> A father? No, there isn't a father. It
doesn't say there is a father.
>> All right. So why are you making things
up that your Quran doesn't say?
>> We don't. Islam isn't about just the
teachings of Quran.
>> Really? So you can you can contradict
the teachings of the Quran and and still
>> No, we're not you're not contradicting.
>> Oh well if if Allah says that he's not a
father cuz he says he's not a father,
right?
>> Where bring up the verse?
>> You you don't you haven't read the
Quran.
>> Have you read the Quran?
>> I just asked you that. Can you answer?
>> You told me that I haven't read the
Quran and you you made a claim.
>> I ended up I ended it with a question
mark. I said you haven't read the Quran.
Huh? meaning that I'm asking you if you
have read it.
>> I'm pretty sure it doesn't say that he's
our father, but
>> okay.
>> Does that mean that he's the father?
>> I'll show you a verse. You ready?
>> Can you show me a verse?
>> Okay,
>> one second. We're going to look around
too.
>> It's chapter 19. We're going to start a
verse.
>> 88. Okay.
>> It says, "And they say the all
merciful."
>> One second. Let me So I'm I'm with you.
1988.
>> Yeah, that's where we're start.
>> Huh? Okay. They say the most
compassionate has offspring. You have
certainly made an outrageous claim by
[clears throat] which the heavens are
about to burst, the earth to spread
apart and the mountains to crumble to
pieces in process of attributing
children to the most compassionate. It
does not befit the majesty of the most
compassion is to have children. There is
none in the heavens or earth who will
not return to the most compassionate
fossil mission. Indeed, he fully knows
them.
>> He has counted them precisely. That's
it. So what does it say that he's
>> So in verse 93, do you read Arabic at
all?
>> Yeah.
So what does that say? Go ahead and
translate because that translation you
just read butchered it. What did it what
did it say in in the Arabic?
All in earth and heaven.
It means that everyone in earth and
heaven is just a slave to God.
>> There you go. Very good. Exactly.
Everyone in the heavens and the earth is
nothing but a slave to Allah. They're
not a They're not a child in any way.
Right.
>> Not in the literal sense.
>> It doesn't say literal. It says the only
It says notice in
>> it says that you are only It says you
are only everyone in the heaven and the
earth is only a slave to Allah. Right.
>> Can I can I answer? Go ahead.
>> Something else.
>> Can can you can you affirm that that's
what it says?
>> Yes. But there you have to be more
inclusive about the Arabic language
because in Arabic when we say
doesn't mean the god of the house. It
means someone who takes care of the
house, someone who who who the people
are in it should submit to
[clears throat] which is
so does that mean that he can he can be
a father in the u in the metaphorical
sense not in the literal sense we reject
the part in the literal sense you you
have to know more about the Arabic
because you can't just say it says this
you have to know more about Arabic
>> okay thank you for that Now let's go
with what the verse says. Does the verse
say that you can be anything other than
a slave to Allah?
>> No, it doesn't. Doesn't think you can be
anything.
>> What is the only relationship according
to the verse? What is the only
relationship you can have with Allah?
>> To submit to his will.
>> A slave, right?
>> Submit to his will and and a slave. Yes.
True.
>> Thank you. Cuz let's stick to what it
says. It says abd, which is slave. So
the only thing you can be to Allah is a
slave. All right. So this so this
eliminates this eliminates any type of
excuse me this eliminates any type of
sense other relationship that you can
have with Allah like a metaphorical
child of his. Right? That's gone
according to this verse. Correct.
>> That's gone. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> That's gone. Yes. So according to this
verse, Allah denies that he is a father
in any sense whether it's literal or
whether it's metaphorical.
He says no. The only thing you are to
him is a slave. Can we agree?
>> Sure.
>> Awesome. So
>> awesome.
>> Now with this being said, Allah denies
being a father in any way. He is only
your lord, only your master. Okay. What
now you have to do is show me that this
is the same concept of God that Jesus
had. That Jesus believed in a God who is
not a father in any sense, who is not
triune, right? He doesn't have partners.
Show me that that's what Jesus believed.
And you got it. You you you'll win the
money.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Thank you. One second.
So it is 193. 1993
1993. Chad GPT.
>> Yeah, [laughter]
>> you know it too. He laughed
me. Save me. I mean, come on. Okay. Can
you fault me for trying to win
>> $2,000?
>> I can't.
>> You can't tell me what to use. You can't
[laughter] tell me what to use.
>> Yeah, I can't fault him, man. This
money, man.
>> Yeah, as long as you are convinced by
actual reason. So, yeah.
>> That's right. I ain't You ain't going to
get no haters from us, man. Go ahead.
>> Hey, come on, man. Come on, man. Come
on, man.
>> Oh, that's
>> He said, "Come on, man. Come on, man.
>> Come on, man. Trying to get this money."
>> Trying to get this money, man.
>> Yeah. Money.
>> Oh, shoot. That's too good. That's too
good.
>> Did anything come up yet?
>> I'm reading.
>> Okay.
>> I was I was
>> All right. While you while you read
that, I'm going to read some super chats
off YouTube. You just talk when you're
ready. Okay.
>> All right.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Jeremy [clears throat] Z
says, "Who's going to tell him? He
already submits to Satan." Oh, that's so
funny.
>> Oh, your problem is that it being the
same God. Yeah. Yeah.
>> The problem is it being the same God.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I get it. I get it. So, it
it is not your problem with him
submitting to God. It is the same God.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> All right. We [clears throat] got a
super chat from Nick who says, "I don't
live too far from Dearbornne. Definitely
will be there. Like their mayor said,
you're more than welcome and we'll have
a parade in the streets upon your
arrival." That's what I'm talking about.
Suave says, "Blessings, bro. Can you get
Lady Logic to put me on with a Hispanic
sister sitting next to her in the Muslim
debate? Need a wife, man. She's already
married, man. [laughter]
>> She's rap."
>> Yeah, she she already wifed up. Big D.
Hold on, man. Shoot. This is way too
funny, bro. Way too funny.
>> How long are you like live for? I'll be
live for another hour and like an hour,
hour and like 30 minutes or something.
Do
>> you think I'll come back in like 50
minutes so I don't like delay the
stream?
>> Sure. Come on back.
>> All right. Take care of yourself.
>> You too.
>> All right. See you later.
>> Yeah. How do I leave? [laughter]
>> I got you. I I put you down.